wir kriegen einen regierungswechsel in
düsseldorf nach all den jahren ist es
normal dass ich mich darüber freue ich
frag mir auch sicher unseren heute-show
betriebsarzt dr christian er ist darf
man sich auf schwarzgeld freund nein
aber ich mache mir da keine herberge die
leiden wie millionen andere deutsche
auch an einer krankheit namens
chronische wähler demenz dementia
idiotie wir haben offensichtlich
komplett vergessen dass wir im bund bis
2013 eine schwarz gelbe koalition ab die
schwarz gelbe koalition da klingelt
nichts wäre es ihr gehirn verdrängt die
traumatische erinnerung
sie wissen dass er jahrelang haben sie
in dieser show nichts anderes gemacht
als billige fdp mit in einer tour live
ausschnitte wie dieser hier jetzt kommen
wir aber zur innenpolitik also da finde
ich alles nicht so schön
die drohne will natürlich erfüllen
ja gute ehring aber damals das war
natürlich die das war die kaltherzige
neoliberale fdp heute haben wir ein ganz
anderes niveau
totaler realitätsverlust klasse oder ein
schläfer konfrontationstherapie wir
wollen uns mal so ich links ihnen aus
dem aktuellen fdp programm für die
bundestagswahl vor zitat wir verteidigen
einen flexiblen arbeitsmarkt sorgen wir
für eine gesellschaft in der wieder
jeder seine zähne durch eigene leistung
erreichen kann
klingt jetzt leistungs
eigenverantwortung die doofe namen sind
selber schuld
alles wie früher und damit man denkt sie
hätten aber neuerdings auch ein herz für
kleine leute sagt die generalsekretärin
ich kann ihnen sagen ich weiß wie hoch
aufrief
christen hochhaus nicht gut aber seit
sie ausgezogen geht wieder
[Applaus]
der punkt ist dass sie vergessen haben
wofür die fdp steht weder die millionen
von deutschen zusätzlich die märkte
wieder soll die ganze wechselstimmung
vom januar wie weggeblasen
eine wechselstimmung natürlich deutschen
hat vier fünf wochen lang mal regelrecht
geliebt wir waren politisiert die
menschen sind plötzlich in parteien
eingetreten in die spd die cdu ganz
doofe so dabei den grünen egal jetzt
fahren wir zurück ins merkel biedermeier
wir pennen wieder ein outlaw motto was
macht sie denn nur 60 prozent der
beschäftigten haben von den
lohnerhöhungen der letzten jahre
profitiert wer abgehängt ist bleibt
abgehängt das ist merkel politik nicht
die flüchtlingskrise
[Applaus]
ja